امام كل هذه المواقف التي تظهر اختلافا
بشكل او باخر مع نتنياهو في هذه المرحله
هل ثمه ما يدل على امكانيه ممارسه ضغوط
امريكيه حقيقيه على رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي حتى اللحظه من غير الواضح يعني
نوعيه هذه الضغوط لطالما كان هناك خلال
الفتره الماضيه حين برزت قضيه هذه
الخلافات خصوصا تلك المتعلقه في اليوم
الذي يلي الحرب على
غزه قضيه ما يقوله البيت الابيض وبشكل
علني بان على اسرائيل ان تتجنب المزيد من
الاذى والاضرار بين المدنيين ان تنتقل
الحمله العسكريه او الحرب في غزه الى وهذا
كان ما ورد ايضا في البيان الذي صدر من
البيت الابيض بشان اتصال بايدن ونتنياهو
الى
مرحله الح حرب او العمليه العسكريه ذات
الاهداف المحدده كل هذا وكل ما يرد بال
الكواليس يبدو ان هناك ضغوط في الكواليس
ولكن حجم هذه الضغوط وان كانت هذه الضغوط
بالفعل قادره او ستصل الى مكان يغير من
مسار هذه الحرب او يغير من المسار الذي
تتخذه اسرائيل يبدو انها لم تفلح حتى
اللحظه خصوصا في ظل التصريحات التي صدرت
عن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو خلال اليومين الماضي
وتحديدا تلك المتعلقه
بمستقبل الدوله الفلسطينيه وحل الدولتين
وهو امر اثار الكثير من الانتقادات هنا في
واشنطن خصوصا من بين المشرعين هناك منهم
مثل اليزابث وارن من يقول انها تصريحات
خطيره وان اي دعم لاسرائيل يجب ان يرتبط
بالعمل من اجل السلام في
المستقبل اعضاء يهود في مجلس النواب
يقولون انهم يختلفون بشده مع هذه
التصريحات وان حل الدولتين هو الحل ما ورد
على لسان جون كيربي بالنسبه للاتصال بين
بايدن ونتنياهو اليوم بان بايدن اعاد
التاكيد على قناعته ورؤيته المتعلقه
بضروره المضيء قدما في حل الدولتين
للمنطقه وانخراط اسرائيل واندماجها في
المنطقه وان الدوله الفلسطينيه المقبله
يجب ان تتمتع بسلام وامن وان ذلك ليس
بالامر السهل اعتراف من البيت الابيض بان
هذا امر يتطلب قياده ويتطلب الكثير من
العمل
واجهد هناك ايضا تحركات اخرى في الكونغرس
على هذه الاداره ضغوط متعلقه بقضيه
المساعدات التي من المتوقع ان يتم التصويت
عليها خلال الاسبوع او الاسبوعين المقبلين
وهي حزمه تعطلت حتى الان بسبب قضايا ليست
متعلقه بالدعم لاسرائيل ولكن الان هناك
مطالبات بان ان يرتبط ذلك الدعم بالالتزام
بالقانون الامريكي والقانون الانساني
الدولي لذا ضغوط على الولايات المتحده هل
ستفلح تلك الضغوط في وضع شروط قد لا تنجح
يعني نظرا لتركيبه مجلس الشيوخ والنواب
ولكنها ضغوط مهمه في مسار على هذه الاداره
نظرا للحصي الكبيره للحرب والتصريحات التي
بات ديمقراطيون يستاؤون منها تصدر عن
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين وموصف في احد
البيانات بالجناح المتطرف او المتطرفين في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه شكرا لكسان ابو كويك
حدثتنا من واشنطن